first news uh we have got great news for
magic mike fans
by the way all the girls and boys can
get excited about that one thank you
usa today reports that hbo max and
channing tatum are teaming up for a new
series to find
the real magic mic it's a reality
competition show and they'll take
a cast of real men who have lost their
magic
and transform them into sexy confident
magic mikes
chris appleton i just have to say
why is this taking so long it's always
women getting a makeover
what do you think absolutely it's about
time the men got a piece of the action i
think
yep by the way chris appleton are you
the real magic mike
i don't know not really even when you're
you look that good if you don't have the
confidence you can't pull it off and i
think that's what they're going to be
looking for in this series which is why
i'm announcing now i'm going to be
auditioning thank you so much
break out the banana hammock that's
coming to vegas
tune in next season okay well we're
talking beauty all week long and one
ingredient taking skincare by storm
is cbd and allure our dear friend
michelle lee
just published a list of their top cbd
products for your beauty routine
to break it down for a second cbd stands
for
cannabidiol all which is the compound
that's
found in the cannabis plant but it's not
the stuff that gets you
funny funny funny so when you use cbd
on your skin and scalp it is believed to
cut down
inflammation it treats so many different
things and now they're incorporating in
beauty products it's amazing
ross we have a product at flower beauty
um my company and this is so exciting
because it made the allure list
of the best cbd products that's
phenomenal
i was really struggling with my dark
circles
like [ __ ] keeper level so i needed to
turn to something
and this has we have light peach
medium peach and deep peach i think i'm
a medium peach um
you are a medium you're right just
perfectly in the middle
and what it does is it has a red
killer and a blue killer so it really
evens out your skin and what you need to
do is put it
under your concealer and it comes in
this beautiful packaging
and you you put this under your eyes and
i showed all these tutorials
of various skin tones and how it really
works
across the spectrum and please run
don't walk because this has been saving
my life awesome i'm so excited to find
out and see what's on ross's radar this
weekend
the roster board yeah it's the ross
report
yes it is the ross report i wrote that
song thank you all right this report is
all about some things that i'm
passionate about and that i want to
recommend to you and to you drew
it can be new or old today it is
something
timeless ladies and gentlemen for your
consideration diane keaton
in baby boom now drew i know you love
this movie too it was released in 1987.
it's about a no-nonsense businesswoman
who subtly inherits
surprise a baby take a quick look
what is it i mean what is it that i
inherited why elizabeth
[Music]
what elizabeth of course your cousin
andrews elizabeth
are you are you joking
didn't mr simpson tell you what
yes it is it was an instant classic
movie and no lie i caught this movie at
least once a day every day the tiger
lady's back drew can i get a co-sign
it's one of my favorite movies of all
time but why do i bring it up now
why well it's not because i'm you
pitching my my sequel
gabey boom no it's because diane keaton
posted a scene from baby boom on her
instagram
last week and people started commenting
oscar winners natalie portman was in
there
someone named ross matthews commented in
the comments as well and guess what
diane keaton wrote back oh look at that
see those hearts she's writing tonight
hello ross heart
heart heart heart heart which i think
basically means diane keaton and i are
best friends
and on social media she's on fire she
does these diane by design videos where
she gives you a tour of her favorite
fashion accessories in her closet
tips on how to wear them just for
funsies let's watch her show us
how to wear a hat sometimes when your
husband comes in you might want to
surprise him with a hat
maybe he likes you like that you could
kiss a little and
maybe take a little further hats are
worth it i'm telling you
i don't think they get enough attention
somebody had to say it thank you diane
keaton
she even blew up on twitter this week
for her sense of style this is her
filming in palm springs
i saw this did you see this yeah this
was everywhere the boots
hello what she's amazing i know she's
diane keaton she's my style icon
uh and did you know drew that she
follows you on instagram and she follows
the drew barrymore
show on instagram which means diane
keaton is watching right now so very
quick
hi oh my god i went to a hotel in san
diego that's like little rooms on a pier
because she uh recommended it in a
magazine
yeah and then i'm there and i look over
who's there diane keaton
i think we should reach out to her and
see if she'll ever come away with that
oh my god and if she says no then fine
we still love you anyway absolutely so
she's my raw support today and i just
want to let you know if anyone out there
wants to watch baby boom you can find it
on like
amazon prime or apple tv all under four
dollars check her out i think it's
a very very poignant that movie
i think it is too because it's about
redefining having it all
on your terms yes exactly seriousness
you